[Music]
welcome back to after record where we
talk about whatever we
want how's that walk guys good it's hot
everyone's cooling down in here he's
like i stayed back behind after lunch
to study for jk news and everyone else
went out for a walk
i went on a bike ride i've been doing
these walks daily to try to like burn a
little extra calories
it actually adds up how many calories do
you burn a day so like four
days i don't know
this walk it was about 126 calories so
like almost 150 so that's like a rice
krispie treat that's nothing yeah but
that's not the point i'm trying to make
oh what's the point you're trying the
point i'm trying to make
is when it comes to fitness you're work
you're always trying to manage
like your workout and your fatigue right
like when you train
you get tired and when you get tired it
affects the next workout
oh hell yeah so like so that's why it's
hard to run like back to back or it's
hard to like train
like every single day hard like hard
that way but um when i've been
doing my workouts and then at night when
i walk or during my lunch time when i
walk just for 30 minutes
it adds up to an extra three mile run
that i would have done but does
zero damage on my body so that's where
the benefits come in it's not really the
100 calories that i burn right now
but it's like the 700 extra calories
before the week
that it's like parking far at the mall
so you could
add a few more steps and then it adds up
without your legs getting tired
and without destroying like a squat
workout or whatever the next day that's
where it really helps out
just as to what the calories were yeah
holy [ __ ] do you
do you dance that's very practical
advice you could dance
i dance guys this guy's like a fitness
channel or something huh
are you the kind of person that parks
further away then from the mall or from
the restaurant
no i parked so you don't actually put it
into a park inside the mall
and then i run back outside and
[Laughter]
not in vegas dude during the summer
you're going to be a boy who parked very
close to the door
the bottom my shoe is going to melt off
yeah exactly i bet there's so much
parking in vegas anyway
there's parking hunt dude you parked
where the [ __ ] you want yeah dude
that's anywhere that's like a dream
parking someone else's parking lot and
they're like yeah it's all good go ahead
hey you're my neighbor aren't you
everyone's a classic classic las vegas
accent a lot of irish people moving to
vegas right now
really oh yeah yeah irish oh sure sure
really oh there's a lot of californians
moving to vegas
i think so oh we did are all your
neighbors ex-californians uh
no one of them was a florida guy but
he's been back and forth florida vegas
he loves it and then my other neighbor
was from san francisco but he moved to
vegas 15 years ago and he's as a
californian do you go ugh i can't
believe other californians are moving
here
no no that'd be [ __ ] up well i would i
would do
i do i do uh like you know sometimes
when you accidentally cut someone off
or you uh you like i don't know you
you're speeding yeah you break one of
the traffic rules on accident
and since i still have california plates
i'm like [ __ ] i'm getting california
it's a bad name
i do that too that's why people are
gonna build it i [ __ ] hate people
from california it's because of people
like me
i'm like oh i feel so bad why don't you
have your nonvatta plate
double down double down roll down the
window be like california forever
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
yeah and it's instead of c for
california it's with the k
you see those t-shirts no california
with the k yeah
like a kill you know it's like more it's
more broke
the thing i miss in the valley of that
that california has is the big trucks
with the big nuts hanging off
love it nevada does not have why not it
looks like one of those states that
would
it's basically a flirty red state isn't
it i think it's a flirty redstone it's a
flirty redstone blurry red state yeah
it's like flirting with being a red
state a little bit
yeah it's probably red just right out of
the strip right
basically it's probably red all the way
around
in all directions truck nuts is
definitely like a red state move i think
that's what you need then
you need these truck nuts some truck
nuts put some on the tesla
just some red ones some red bulls i
don't know what time it is
you should get like a hologram truck nut
for the tesla so it [ __ ] projects a
truck i want it to look like
life like you know what it means to kind
of like you really have to see it dude
in my fantasy football league if you're
the
last place you have to put truck nuts on
your car that's it that's pretty good
that seems kind of mild well you also
have to hold a sign next to a freeway
that says i suck at fancy football
for an hour an hour damn not so good
people honk your whole heart behind you
and laugh at you cause you suck a
fantasy so bad
that's good i like it when there's like
steaks like that yeah you need it that
might be better you know when you're
when you bet on boxing fights it might
be better to just best
bet on dares like that the accumulation
yeah that's what you need if people are
pouring like i can't bet right now it's
like guess what you can [ __ ]
you got an hour you're gonna stand your
fly sign next to a freeway and have
truck nuts on your car
what happens if you win in your league
oh nothing
you get to enjoy it sounds like a jk
party challenge if you're playing did
not lose if you're like
[ __ ] mayweather's gonna lose but then
if you if he wins
then you have to have a sign that says
mayweather's my dad
i think it's like 200 bucks i like when
people are that competitive that all
they want is just the bragging
like well that's really what it is
because 1200 bucks like it's great and
all but
like everyone in our league we all just
want to [ __ ] beat each other because
we've known each other for a decade
so we just want to destroy each other is
there any of your family in it no
[ __ ] friends
well they don't care about football the
way that you have to care about football
you're going to be in a fancy football
how did you care about football so much
of knowing your family career i've
always liked football like i swear i'm
like
i'm an anathema like my dad and my oh
what the [ __ ] am i
i'm uh i'm like an outlier right i'm
like against my
the grain of my what's the difference
between anathema and an anomaly
anomaly is like an uh an error something
that happens like
strangely like out of nowhere and but
i'm like
abnormality but i'm like going against
the tide almost in my family
anathema yeah i'm gonna use that the
idea of it is that contrarian guy
yeah in my own family i'm like where the
[ __ ] did i come from who who am i
related to because i'm so unlike all the
introverts
yeah in my family it's very awkward so
is it is it because
your mom [ __ ] a mailman i think it
might be because she [ __ ] the mailman
yeah
a tall mailman they're not milkman
anymore back in the day used to be the
milkman
and then for a little bit in the 70s a
pool boy now it's the mailman
or maybe the postmates amazon guy
yeah amazon guys are usually different
aren't they i feel like they're always
different yeah
kind none maybe and post mates guys
aren't they all different too they're
right okay i [ __ ] that fight
you gotta build a rapport i always feel
bad when the postmates person sends
their kids to do their job oh yeah true
sometimes you're like ding dong and you
open the door and it's like an
eight-year-old with like
two bowls of [ __ ] yeah i'm like but
that's how they get you to tip though
yeah but you don't think
good for you teaching them how to
[ __ ] work early true
you know i child labored myself like i
couldn't wait and i begged my parents to
put me to work and [ __ ] what age uh as
soon as i knew what work was and i could
make money
first or second grade you took the
initiative yourself you're not like the
dad who brings his kid on shark tank and
has him like do a memorized pitch
just to get the [ __ ] heart strings
going as he's reading it because my
parents were like embarrassed like we're
not [ __ ] poor you don't have to do
this [ __ ] and i'm all like no
[ __ ] i want my own money exactly yeah
were you trying to work
to actually make money or work to work
once i figured out what money was
i i was like wait so you could you
telling me that these things
i could get everything like everything
you see
and then that's when i was like what i
gotta get [ __ ] money
well you got it wrong right for the
first year or so because i think you
were
yeah so like um i blew my i got in big
trouble because i blew my allowance
at the baseball card store where i
bought like a bunch of pogs
and then um i sold it at school and i
told my parents i was like
yo i [ __ ] sold it all out in one day
and then my dad was like oh that's so
cool and then i was telling him my plan
i was like yeah so i wanted to
beat the the baseball card store i was
like i was gonna sell it i sold it for
half off
so i bought it like let's say i bought
it for like 10 bucks for the whole stack
i was like and i bought and i sold each
of them and i got five bucks back
i didn't i didn't know what profit was
yet but i'm gonna repeat this process
i'm gonna buy five bucks and go down to
250.
i should do 125 and ball making money
because my mind was competitive right
i'm like
well why would they buy from me if they
could buy from them for the same price i
gotta beat them somehow right
and then he was like no you [ __ ]
dumbass you gotta and i wouldn't listen
to him i'm like no i won look at all
this money
and i didn't really know matt that well
so then like i had a lot of money like i
had coins i had dollars i had a lot like
a mountain i'm like you only gave me one
paper
like look at all the monies i got look
how many papers i have that yeah did you
say he kicked your ass
he [ __ ] me up because of like i was
being stubborn too how old were you i
was a kid
i was like i was a like first or second
grade at least you kicked that stubborn
habit of yourself
you got that one lead i love that story
i'll never let that story die i know
right
next sucks is like how much of a caveman
like our parents were
you never [ __ ] done okay well this is
a lot of paper you're right
add all of it up and then see how much
the final value i swear my dad tried
i think he tried i could just see him
like he doesn't know what the [ __ ] to do
anymore
oh i would have kicked your ass too
because i would just fight him until i
yeah i remember my dad i made like 20
from doing yard work or whatever
and my dad wanted to give me uh like
different denominations and i just
wanted a 20
yeah i didn't understand that he's
giving me two fives and a bunch of ones
and that's the same as twenty dollars
yeah cause i'm like no give me the big
one [ __ ] you man and i was like super
upset about it i was like five years old
or whatever
where did you store your money in a
piggy bank card put it in a piggy bank
yeah i had a little i had like a clear
piggy bank that i put money in i used to
have uh you know like the you remember
what checkbooks used to come in that box
oh yeah
so i had that in my drawer that's and i
would always put like my dollar in there
two dollars and like every day i would
open it and like
count it check books haven't changed
they still come the exact same way
yeah that's like never evolved when's
the last time you cut a check
dude last month i mean the [ __ ] way
she's the one with all the checks i got
a checkbook right here dude just in case
are you kidding oh [ __ ] are you a 1950s
mom
why do you have a checkbook for the
supermarket why are you wearing your
face you're one of them huh
oh i just keep it on me at all in the
supermarket i [ __ ] hate you you're
that [ __ ] i'm behind
holding up the line oh that's right
people used to write checks at
supermarkets
are you balancing it too yeah i gotta do
it before and then i'll write the check
that's what i do oh right do people even
learn how to balance
checks steve is gonna punch me in the
face dude
he's like better get your d up dude i'm
sorry yeah get your defense and they go
like oh would you like to donate
a dollar to hungry children they're like
i'll write a second
i always write the second journey
what's the organization's name how long
is it why is it so long yeah my mom
still does it when do you think they're
gonna be gone
what do you think checks are to be when
all those old people are right
they no i still use cash is almost
[ __ ] yeah because of what happened
during covet
all the coin shortages when shortages
dude i was like that could happen
where did they go why wouldn't there's
no more something
makeup bro they want to track your money
more come on
short as my [ __ ] ass
they just took them up they want you to
use your debit lost the molds
that's what they said they they it broke
they broke and then they
asked china i thought it was a metal
shortage because uh
but also our coins cost more than what
they actually are
exactly because the metal costs more
they finally just got
busted to joe in first grade basically
hey that's what our financial system is
hanging on you were ahead of your time
joe you didn't even know it
i do i was doing it right i always was
trying to hustle but i know i feel like
it's a
poor kid thing because when i was at
school a lot of kids had like side
hustles they were selling candy
they were selling stuff they always had
like yard sales or whatever i was doing
that yeah
so i thought it was normal yeah yeah
well it's interesting like
your your parents were like we're not
poor you don't even do this [ __ ]
you know like that's an interesting like
mindset to kind of come from because
it's
it is true because a lot of parents it's
embarrassing i work hard so you don't
have to do this [ __ ]
yeah and i'm like i want to work but
it's really you just exercising
your inner entrepreneur you just want to
make your own yeah i guess so
because my friend's dad had a truck
washing company and i
begged them to take me and work and i
didn't give a [ __ ] like
how much they're paying me per hour or
whatever but
it was like you know like those
arrowhead trucks or whatever and we
would wake up at like
four or five in the morning and this was
me at like 12 or 13.
yeah and we're out there washing trucks
and his dad was scary dude he was like
he's like this big wrestler looking dude
like
this like you know like imagine like a
big white truck driver
right and he cusses like crazy and he's
loud like
and i remember one time he um his name
is joseph too so he was sitting right
here in the middle
and his dad was over there and he was
trying to get some stuff in between
and under the truck uh seat and he's
like spread your [ __ ] legs like a
[ __ ] and move
them and i was like oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] like a [ __ ]
spread your [ __ ] legs like a [ __ ]
and move them i was like
[ __ ] dude oh man it was he was
scared yeah did you do it he spread his
legs now i was on the side like this
and then you go home and like hey mom
i'm gonna go wash drugs with this guy
yeah and we still went but i got used to
him but yeah i get used to something
like that
i don't know well the difference was he
would never beat his kid
so like in our household like things
would start flying
emotional abuse yeah so i was like i was
like
holy [ __ ] are you gonna get [ __ ]
spanked right now and then it doesn't
happen
so i was like okay and then i remember
one time we got hungry we got spam and
we were like
cooking some spam and then the next day
he goes
i should [ __ ] both of you up right now
you know i was
i was mopping the kitchen floor all last
night after work
because you had [ __ ] grease all over
the floor
and then i was just like i'm sorry i'll
clean it up
yeah it was pretty crazy did you have a
bowl haircut please tell me you did uh
no at that time i had bangs
i had raver bangs so i was like i had
these raver bangs just dangling
can you get the full haircut back no
that was like being in third grade
but i want it back my friend's dad was a
sparklets guy and they were much nicer
yeah i want to see joe with bangs yo i
had rave bangs man like this
like [ __ ] was the rest bald it was
like this yeah it was bald
edwards with your hands huh did you ice
the tips no i didn't i never
dyed anything and then i had this too
where it was like this and then you just
shave everything else because i didn't
know how to do a fade and i just flipped
it back
what was your first job casey my first
job was a
i was packaging i don't know like wires
or some [ __ ] like like
computer parts like like actual like
computer like hardware parts into bags
and i would ship them out that was my so
you're a packer packer yeah i guessed
that
a computer store no out of i don't know
what the [ __ ] i was
where i was at it was just like a
warehouse thing i was just packing [ __ ]
how'd you find that job my dad hooked me
up
yeah i was like oh my client's got a
position in his warehouse and uh go go
work
for summer yeah i was the kind of kid
though like growing up i don't
understand that mentality and i'm like
maybe i i i don't my parents would try
to get me to do things around the house
for money and i'd be like
how much work is it going to take for me
to do that am i going to break a sweat i
have to calculate all that and i'm like
is it worth the 20
that they're offering me nope you're
just not a don't know like joe and i
dude
so what about if you wanted money do you
just go oh [ __ ] i just won't get that
thing i just won't get the thing i'm
just like [ __ ] whatever
my my dad said he would give me five
bucks to wash the car i watched it three
times so i could get more money
the same day i said i watched it three
times give me 15.
five times in one day no three times
like 15. yeah for five bucks
did he give you the 15. he laughed at me
he just gives me one
five dollars but i'm like i did it three
times though
that's [ __ ] smart i watched it once
wiped it down
and then i [ __ ] soaked it again wiped
it down and soaked it again and wiped it
down this makes so much sense about joe
if you give me five i understand joe now
i get joe now too he mows your lawn four
times he's like i did it four times [ __ ]
you is 40 bucks
like this is like your spider-man origin
story you should have got some dirt and
just put it back on the car like oh
really you want to pay one all right
well i guess it's already again
that's the bart smart side right
he knows okay problem solution i just go
solution solution solution solution
solution
let me fix your problem over and over
and over i find the solution yeah
you just gotta have a polaroid where you
take you wash the car the first time
before and after
and then you throw dirt on it oh no
where does this come from
see it was dirty again on the same day i
don't know how this is why you guys are
such a match made in heaven
because i'll figure out how to keep
fixing it barb would find the problem
tree fell on tree sap fell all over the
house he was like oh no
we better clean it you're the
destructive side and he
fixes everything i was like that too
where i really wanted to make money
so once my mom started putting dollar
prices on like
clean you empty out the bottom of the
toaster oven is this much you wash this
is
was this much you you vacuumed the
living room it was this i was trying to
like
accumulate all of those things i paint i
get to do house [ __ ]
[ __ ] no no that's not my mom i agree
that's his [ __ ] job what if he
doesn't
what if he refuses to do it kick his ass
yeah then he just can't have the
privileges it's like you make choices
and with those choices just do the
things we can't talk about on camera to
him stupid
patreon you're fine dude all right
patreon yeah yeah slam him against the
door
you know he [ __ ] put his finger in
the door hinges just slam the door
shut did you guys like working
like working just to learn stuff because
it was fun pretending
or or did you like it because the money
because like my friends
i child labor myself at his restaurant
and i remember bringing food out and i
spilt it on a lady and she was like is
he even old enough to be done with this
and like she was like a mean karen then
i ran away
um but like i was at my family friend's
farm and we were working there and all
this [ __ ] was fun to me
but dude you spilled on her and you
called her mean karen
scary that yeah a caring because he she
realized that he's really young
and she didn't cut him any slack he
spilled on her [ __ ]
[ __ ] that well what did you spill in
here i don't know blazing hot soup it
was like
it was like taco juice or whatever i
don't know it was like
i i couldn't [ __ ] hold it i was
little it was too heavy
yeah i don't know but she chewed me out
and [ __ ] and i
i already said sorry but then i was like
[ __ ] that and then
i was still down to like work and put
[ __ ] out and then his grandma was like
we we we're not going to go on that side
of the restaurant and i went to the
other side instead
i think i like things uh because of the
money aspect because it was immediate
gratification
you know if it was like hey if you if
you vacuum this floor then i'll pay you
like
i don't know 50 cents or something and
then as soon as you're done vacuuming
before you get paid
you're like oh cool like there's a
before and after versus like my mom will
try to do the exact same thing
all right so now if you that same
concept
you study and then you get a on the test
i'll give you five bucks it's way more
but because it's like
okay so you're telling me how to study
for a [ __ ] whole month when the test
comes around in like 30 days
i don't think i could wait that long oh
so i think like the immediate
gratification of things
even before the money comes cleaning
shoes or mowing the lawn or what all
those things it's like
before you even get paid like you have
the self-satisfaction versus like
trying to study and then like afterwards
you you feel more like a nerd too
you're like [ __ ] [ __ ] kind of
ashamed of myself not saying no more
[ __ ]
what the [ __ ] then you gotta wait like
30 days this guy dude
i don't know who's smart i'm gonna keep
my own ass i know you're like the
ultimate nerd right now yeah
when it comes to like knowing [ __ ] and
like like [ __ ]
nerd nerd you should walk to boom with
calories this [ __ ] yeah
dude i've read that somewhere dude you
should [ __ ] walk because i read it
on instagram i read it off for instance
i do write that a lot online here's the
thing
it all adds up okay
all right dude we get it you work out
bro jesus
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you